good morning Hank it's Wednesday come
with me to speak at the United Nations
so Sarah and I first visited a picnic
for TB survivors and activists and then
attended a pre- meting meeting and then
the next day went to another pre- meting
meeting which you would think I'd find
unbearable but actually I loved it
because I love hating tuberculosis so
much plus I got to see one of my heroes
Dr luch D and another one of my heroes
the writer and surgeon Dr Atul Gand and
another one of my heroes Dr s kavi for
me being able to see these folks in real
life is a little bit like how my
daughter would feel about seeing both
Olivia Rodrigo and Taylor Swift in the
same night and then afterwards they were
like hey do you want to go out to dinner
and I was like uh yes and I got to hang
out with them even more and tried to
keep my cool so I didn't film that
because I'm cool and I'm relaxed and I'm
a normal person just like the world's
leading TB Fighters the next morning it
was time for the meeting itself which of
of course meant that it was also time
for a fit check now I have a 40 minute
walk to the United Nations which I'm
going to spend just luxuriating in my
anxiety as I walked I thought about
whether I'd have a chance to speak and
what I would say and what an honor it is
to represent not just nerd Feria and
Partners in Health but also people who
survived TB and those who didn't so I
made it to the grounds of the UN where
there's this phenomenally beautiful
landscaping that some of the richest
people in the world get to look down on
which in my business is known as a
metaphor and then I got inside where
everything was for lack of a better term
extraordinarily United Nations e this is
cool I got to wear the earpiece that
does live translating and look at all
the representatives from around the
world and celebrate with other TV
activists when the political Declaration
on tuberculosis was formally approved
now the Declaration includes big targets
for reducing TB in the next few years
which if honored will save millions of
of lives but of course it's only a piece
of paper unless Nations and their
leaders fund and Implement all the
initiatives outlined in it this was the
second highlevel meeting on tuberculosis
and I was thinking about how at the last
one in 2018 Shrea trapathy was still
alive Shrea was a teenager who sued her
own government in India to secure access
to the life-saving medication baline for
herself and others and she was also a
fan of my book The fult in Our Stars
her fight took her to India's highest
court where she eventually won but by
then it was too late for her her lungs
were simply too damaged for her to
survive and so in the end her death was
caused not just by
tuberculosis but also by government
bureaucracy and international
indifference to TB and so I was thinking
about Shrea as the UN people told me
that actually I would have a chance to
speak as long as I kept it under 2
minutes I wish I'd said more that this
is a problem of resource allocation that
disease does not treat people equally
unless Society treats people equally
that we cannot go on promising to
address this crisis without making the
choices and sacrifices necessary to
enact those promises but here's what I
did say I want to begin by saying that
23 years ago Dr Peter mueni in a room
very much like this one said of HIV
medication where are the drugs the drugs
are where the disease is not and where
is the disease the disease is where the
drugs are not and that is the situation
that we are in today with tuberculosis
The Cure is where the disease is not and
the disease is where the Cure is not we
have had a disease that is that is
curable for 75 years that continues to
kill 1.6 million people and maybe it was
possible to say in the 19th century the
death from tuberculosis was caused by a
bacterium called M tuberculosis but we
can really no longer say that today we
have to accept the reality that since we
know how to kill that bacteria we know
how to cure this disease today we have
to accept the reality that death from
tuberculosis is caused by human-built
systems by human choice we have chosen
the world that we share today and we can
choose a better world we are currently
choosing a world where 1.6 million
people die of tuberculosis and I believe
that with your help together working
over the next decade we will choose a
world where no one dies of tuberculosis
thank
[Applause]
you in I hope I did okay and I hope that
sha somehow knows that we are still
fighting for her and will continue to do
so until the fight is finished Hank I'll
see you tomorrow